we've just learned that the upcoming
january 6 trump riot committee hearings
which start thursday night in prime time
will reportedly include video of
testimony from donald trump's daughter
ivanka trump and of testimony from
donald trump's son-in-law ivanka's
husband jared kushner both key players
in the trump administration now
this may not achieve anything but it
should serve to shed some serious light
on what took place we're going to look
at the new report about this remember
that jamie raskin last week told us
we are we are bringing the heat we are
going to be exposing some serious things
during these committee hearings uh and
then there's a question of who we'll be
watching but we'll talk about that in a
moment huffington post report january
6th panel to reportedly air ivanka trump
and jared kushner videotapes the house
select committee investigating last
year's insurrection is gearing up for
its national debut of hearings that will
include videotaped interviews with
ivanka trump and jared kushner per the
washington post on thursday select
committee chair benny thompson and vice
chair liz cheney will launch the series
of televised hearings featuring both
live witnesses and taped interviews
including several white house figures
both trump and kushner served as senior
advisers in donald trump's white house
during the insurrection last year
their interviews have been described to
the post as gripping
i think we don't have any idea how
insane these hearings are going to be
yet the committee will attempt to place
the violence at the capitol on january
6th in a broader context of a
wide-ranging scheme to overturn a
legitimate presidential election with
trump's involvement serving as the
through line cassidy hutchinson a top
aide to the former white house chief of
staff mark meadows is expected to play a
key role she's already reportedly
provided the committee with extensive
information about meadows activities
aimed at overturning the election the
final hearing will focus mainly on trump
what he did and what he said before and
on january 6th any remaining bombshells
will be revealed by then
this is a very very big deal now will
anybody be watching these hearings
i don't know
uh
it's
you know if a tenth of the adult
population were to watch it live i'd i'd
be surprised i'm not particularly
optimistic right now that this is going
to garner the large mainstream audience
i think in our world this is going to be
huge for people who follow shows like
ours
and i want this to break through into
the mainstream i wish we didn't have
circumstances where lots of people are
fine either having no idea what happens
at such a hearing
or
being told by fox news the next day what
took place because we can guess that the
story that the mainstream media will
tell will be at best incomplete and the
story that right-wing weaponized media
like fox news newsmax and oan will tell
will be actively deceptive it will
likely get a lot of media coverage but
the question is how much interest will
there be from americans in the hearings
themselves the uh primary sources as i
like to call them and unfortunately we
have this status quo in the united
states where you've got a lot of dis
casually right-wing disinterested
americans who
aren't interested in watching something
for hours
but are very happy to be told the next
morning on fox and friends by pete
hegseth or ainsley earhart
what they should believe about what took
place and you can expect that they are
going to say
because they're already sort of saying
it these hearings are a distraction well
from what the hearings are a distraction
from the real stories
biden inflation
biden gas prices
biden formula shortage
the
biden failure in ukraine
uh
do you know what is it the the audit
going on in whatever state there's even
still an audit going on and so at the
end of the day the core question we care
about
is what might come from the hearings the
hope would be
just obvious overwhelming evidence of
criminality that the justice department
can't ignore the the dream scenario
would be what is presented in prime time
for everybody who wants to see it to see
is so
undeniably criminal in what it exposes
that the doj has to take it up that's
the dream
uh and that's what we talked about
earlier in the context of former
attorney general eric holder saying
that's what he expects not everybody is
expecting that but that's what eric
holder expects
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler cube and the dock pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 off of the uhler
and cube sleep systems and 10 off the
new dock pro this offer is only for my
audience the link is down below